now emails first reported by the new
york post
show frequent communication between the
american federation of teachers and
top cdc officials just days before the
invited administration released its
school reopening guidelines
in one email a teachers union official
writes it would be great to see the
insertion of some variation of the
following
in the event high community transmission
results from a new variant of sars cove
2
a new update of these guidelines may be
necessary
in at least two instances language
suggestions
offered by the union were reportedly
adopted nearly verbatim
into the final text of the cdc document
but the aft in a statement to fox news
saying quote
the aft represents 1.7 million educators
health care professionals and public
employees who spent the last 14 months
serving on the front lines of the kovid
19 pandemic
so naturally we have been in regular
touch with the agencies setting policy
that affect their work and lives
including the cdc in fact we contacted
the agency more in 2020 during the trump
administration
than we have during the biden
administration in 2021
but republicans say the report shows the
binded administration is putting
politics ahead of science
by consulting one of its largest donor
groups here's senator tom cotton on the
faulkner focus
a short time ago we shouldn't have a
politicized public health bureaucracy
like the cdc
answering at the beck and call of the
teachers unions we need
kids back in school and back in real
school not sitting in a classroom
doing a zoom session with teachers who
are not in the classroom
we need kids in schools with their
teachers now
carl welcome to you and i'd like to
start and get your thoughts on this to
begin with
now in these emails that have now been
published pursuant to a foia request
we know that the aft called the cdc a
quote thought partner
and that in those emails expressed that
they were grateful for the cdc's quote
genuine desire to earn their confidence
and that begs the question whether
confidence means donations
the aft and its affiliates have long
been one of the most reliable
and deep pocketed donor constituencies
of the democratic party
rising up to almost 20 million dollars
in donations in the 2020 election cycle
in fact the aft is ranked 27th
out of 22 000 in contributors
your thoughts carl yeah let's come back
to that money question in a minute
i thought it was disingenuous with the
aft how the aft
responded they're saying look first of
all we talked more to the
trump administration in 2020 than we've
talked to the biden administration in
2021 well maybe that's because
the trump administration was in charge
of this coven issue from february of
2020
through january 20th of 2021
and joe biden has only been in charge of
this from january 20th
through today so there's a lot more time
that they would be talking to the cdc
and the second and more important point
to my perspective is this
it's not just the cdc they're talking to
they have the white house included
in these emails including the office of
public liaison
when i was at the white house i was in
charge of that office the people who ran
it reported to me
that's your outreach group that's the
people who are talking to your allies
and associates
out there to try and advance your agenda
so let's not kid ourselves this is not
the aft the the teachers union talking
to some career government employed the
cdc
they were including the biden white
house in these discussions
subtly sending the message to the cdc
hey we got friends at 1600 pennsylvania
avenue
you better be doing what we suggest
which is laying the predicate for us to
have more schools
that are not holding in person in
classroom instruction
so i i thought that's a particularly
thuggish move and
you know you'll notice they glossed over
it they weren't just talking to the cdc
they were talking to the white house and
using the white house leverage to get
from the cdc
what they wanted that's exactly right
kaylee this was indeed a triad
in those emails and and when pressed by
jake tapper
the cdc director multiple times he said
specifically i'm quoting her
can you point to any scientific reason
for students in the united states
not to return to in-person classes
tomorrow
director wallensky could not or would
not offer a scientific explanation
right because there wasn't a scientific
reason there was a political reason
it was the influence of the teachers
union i thought the biden administration
followed the science they passionately
proclaimed that but in fact
they have the teachers union dictating
the science this is extraordinary i
think this is a huge scandal
we knew back in july when i stood at the
white house podium that schools
should be reopened the data showed us
that i said it multiple
times as did president trump and others
and here we are
down the road and the teachers union is
reviewing guidance
they actually got to review the guidance
there at the cdc
before it came out you have if you
listen very carefully to president biden
and his words he will say
we should probably reopen schools in the
fall he said that as recently as last
week
even though every teacher will have had
an opportunity to be vaccinated and
older children
over the age of 16 as well uh it is
incredible and
the disproportionate impact here falls
on young working moms we saw that new
york times op-ed today
which said the biggest gender issue of
our time
will be working moms who cannot go back
to work
who have young children and are forced
to stay home and we see that they're
going back into the workforce
at a much lower rate than men and
president biden you are directly
responsible for that gender and equality
gap we're seeing
kennedy as the new york times puts it
the biggest issue of gender equality in
2021
may well be whether schools return to
near normal in the fall
yeah and and that is especially true for
younger children children in preschool
and you know obviously preschools are
not beholden
by large to the department of education
and you know they have
been following some of this guidance as
well and they've been
very sporadically opening and serving
families
and when it comes to families you don't
hear about learning you don't hear about
parents
parents are left completely out of these
discussions it's really just
about this massive power grab from the
union
and here they are writing the language
for the cdc that's getting
inserted into their recommendations so
how instrumental was the aft
and writing some of the coveted relief
legislation that gave schools 130
billion dollars
up to 200 billion dollars that you know
most of it doesn't even get to the
schools for another three years
so yes they donated 20 million to
democratic
campaigns in 2020 and that's so they can
look over politicians shoulders
and write this legislation for them so
it benefits them completely when i say
them
i mean the teachers union i don't even
mean teachers it's definitely not
students it's not kids who are in most
need of the services that are provided
at school particularly mental health
and some of the the food
supplementation that is given to them on
a daily basis
from these public schools and they're
the ones who are completely
left out in the cold especially middle
schoolers and high schoolers they don't
care if they ever come back frankly
and carl we see that direct influence on
legislation obviously
i mean even thought with the greater new
york hospital associations they're
writing that immunity clause for
themselves that made it into new york's
budget
so back to the white house how is it
possible for them to maintain with a
straight face
that they are impervious to political
influence that they are only following
the science
when here now it is laid out in black
and white before our eyes
well kennedy touched on it the american
federation of teachers is one of the
most powerful
and most uh generous uh political givers
as you pointed out
they gave 19 million 900 3 000
in political contributions in 20 in the
2020 election cycle virtually all of it
to democrat candidates virtually all of
it just a handful of gifts to a handful
of republicans
think about this in the school funding
in the covent relief bill the buy
not the bipartisan bills passed last
year not the five measures that got wide
bipartisan support
we're talking about the biden
administration straight party line vote
129 billion dollars in edge
in in public education funding that
means for every dollar in campaign
contributions
they got six thousand four hundred and
eighty one dollars and twenty six cents
in covent relief money now why is that
important because the cdc in december
said we need to remediate the effects of
covet in oliver public schools
up to 422 dollars for each one of the 50
million
plus students in our public schools
which was roughly then 21 billion
dollars
and that's assuming that you remediated
the
the entire transportation system of the
schools which turns out to be far more
expensive
than remediating the classrooms
themselves and protecting the students
so all they really needed was 21 billion
dollars and kennedy's right
most of that money very little of that
money gets spent this year
out of the coveted relief bill the
remediation money gets spent
the rest of it gets spent over the next
decade in fact more money is spent in
the last six years of the decade
that is being spent this year in on
education including the remediation
efforts
so look this is a big giant expensive
gift
to the to the to the to the teachers
union and they got it in part because
they
they gave a lot of political money and
they provide a lot of political muscle
to democratic candidates
it's not pretty uh imagine what would
happen fill in the blank of if you did
that for a republican group that gave
political money
and you can imagine what the headlines
would be in the washington post in the
new york times
uh carl i'm just gonna to get in a quick
word on that and then we're gonna move
to
to what's happening with governor cuomo
that's breaking right now
but the thought of that being in the
last six years that spending that would
mean that the children who really paid
the highest price
educationally throughout the pandemic
some of them won't even be in school
still
right they'll be in this middle school
and high school grades they won't even
get to benefit from that spending
and look the biggest benefit to these
children is to get them back in the
classroom
the schools have gotten budgets for that
they've got their annual budgets get
them back in class
and that to me is just amazing that the
that the teachers union is trying to
find yet another excuse
to keep a generation of our young
children from
learning as they should and and and
reaching the goals that they need
in order to have a successful life what
is going to happen to this last
this lost year and they want to turn it
into more than a lost year
and have the authority to do so it's
like senator cotton said to me we were
talking about how you know the teachers
union basically just gave its homework
to the white house and they put some of
that in along with the cdc
right into their their new guidelines